Sapiosexuals... and 8 other language facts
1.
Sapiosexual is the scientific name for a person
who is sexually attracted to people’s intelligence
The first part of the word comes from the
Latin “sapiens”, meaning “wise”.
(QF 640)
2.
A contronym is a word that can be its own
opposite for example, “left” can mean
to “depart” and “remain”.
(QF 430)
3.
You may have heard that “swag” comes from
a 1960s acronym for “Secretly We Are Gay”.
In fact, the noun, “swag”, dates back
at least to the 14th century meaning “bulky
bag”.
It then morphed into meaning a “blustering
fellow” by the late 16th century and by
the late 18th century had come to mean “ornamental
festoon” (festoon meaning some sort of adornment
like flowers or ribbons and other decorations).
(QF 664)
4.
“Are you as bored as I am?”
read backwards is the same sentiment, just
one is introspective.
(QF 624)
5.
You may have heard that the longest English
word in which all the letters are in alphabetical
order with no letter repeated is “almost.”
Well, almost.
The actual winner is Aegilops, the name of
a genus of flowering plants in the grass family,
Poaceae.
Aegilops comes from the Greek aegilos and
in free translation means “an herb liked
by goats.”
(QF 716)
6.
The name “taxi” is shortened from “taxicab”.
So where did “taxicab” come from?
It is derived from the two words: “taximeter”
and “cabriolet”.
The taximeter was invented in 1891 and is
used to record distances and calculate the
fare.
Cabriolet refers to a horse drawn carriage
where the driver stands in the back of the
carriage.
The name “taximeter” itself is derived
from the Mid-Latin “taxa”, meaning “tax
or charge”.
The first documented use of the word “taxicab”
was in March of 1907 in London.
Another phrase that derived from taximeter
was a “taxi dancer”, which was a woman
who sold her services at dance halls.
7.
“Hippopotamus” comes from the Greek “Hippo”
meaning “horse” and “potamos”, meaning
“river”, hence “river horse”.
(QF 627)
8.
Synesthesia (meaning literally “together
sensation”) is a condition where when one
sensory pathway is stimulated, a second pathway
will also be automatically stimulated.
In one form of this, for instance, someone
might see the letter “a” and the brain
interprets that letter as being colored red,
even if it’s not.
In another form, someone might see some particular
thing that in turn causes them to hear a sound
every time they see that thing.
In yet another form, known as “mirror touch
synesthesia”, when the person sees someone
getting physically touched, they also feel
as if someone is touching them in the exact
same way.
(QF 643)
9.
The word “gorilla” comes from the Greek
word Γόριλλαι (Gorillai), which was
originally a word applied to an African tribe
noted for having very hairy women, as recorded
by Hanno during his travels along the coast
of Africa in 500 BCE.
The name was applied to the animal in 1847
by missionary Thomas Savage.
(QF 714)